In 2015, the Irish economy grew by
an unprecedented twenty-five percent.
In just 12 short months, it achieved
the previous 12 years worth of growth.
Needless to say, that… doesn’t happen. Anywhere.
The global average that year was 3.1%. Even China
and India could only manage seven and eight.
And yet 2015 wasn’t the only time Ireland exceeded
all possible expectations. Six years
later, its economy grew by nearly 14%.
Today, Ireland is the second-richest country
in the world with a population over one
million. Its per-capita GDP of $104,000
is 36% higher than the United States.
Even more impressive is how recent all this is.
Thirty years ago, Ireland lagged slightly behind
the European average. Now, it’s
almost three times wealthier.
In the 70s, 80s, and 90s, it received
billions of Euros in subsidies from
the EU. Today, it contributes billions of Euros.
Back then, thousands fled the country
in search of greener pastures.
But since 1996, the flow
of migration has reversed;
skilled professionals from around the globe
now relocate to the island every year.
For all these reasons, Ireland has been
called the “Celtic Tiger” — in reference
to the rapid rise of the four “Asian Tigers” —
Hong Kong, Taiwan, Singapore, and South Korea.
There’s just one tiny problem: it’s not… real.
These numbers are all real. And these facts are
technically true. But what they imply is not.
The Irish economic “miracle” is an
elaborate, carefully preserved illusion.
To see why, we need to roll back the clock
to 1980, the year everything changed…
Sponsored by GiveWell — the independent nonprofit
whose rigorous charity research allows you
and I to make the largest possible impact.
In 1980, Apple became the first foreign
tech company to manufacture in Ireland.
According to CEO Tim Cook, it saw in the
country — quote — “a community rich with
talent,” and one that could “accommodate growth.”
And, in the official corporate version of
history, that’s where the story ends. Apple
took a chance on this small, developing nation
and the two grew hand-in-hand. Apple’s press
release for its 40th anniversary repeatedly
refers to its Irish “family” and “community”.
But the timing tells a different story.
Ireland has pursued business-friendly
policies since at least 1956, when it
began offering 10 years of generous
tax breaks to foreign manufacturers.
But after joining what would
become the European Union in 1973,
it agreed to phase out those
incentives starting in… 1981.
Apple, in other words, snuck in the door
right at the eleventh hour — securing
for itself a full decade of tax breaks
during the company’s most vulnerable era.
It was during this period that Steve Jobs
was replaced by the former CEO of Pepsi,
John Sculley, who initiated a major
restructuring. The company was
losing billions of dollars and
bankruptcy was on the horizon.
Ireland wasn’t doing much better. Nearly a
quarter of its population was unemployed.
So, as its 10-year window began to close,
Apple approached the country with an offer:
it would funnel nearly all its worldwide revenue
into Ireland, but it was only willing to pay an
effective tax rate of less than 2%. And while 2%
may not be much, that was 2% the country would
otherwise never see. In return, Apple would have
a safe place to stash its international profits.
Ireland, desperate for whatever
cash it could get its hands on,
accepted this opening bid without negotiation.
The only thing left to do was… write the tax code.
To make this arrangement legal,
it worked backwards, crafting rules that
would artificially produce the 2% figure.
And just like that, Apple
had set its own tax rate.
Now, the reason this was
possible was IRS Form-8832.
Form-8832 doesn’t look like much — it’s
a pretty unassuming three pages. But it
completely transformed the American tax landscape.
Before 8832, U.S. corporations were
required to pay U.S. taxes on their
worldwide income — whether their bananas
were sold in South Carolina or South Africa.
Until recently, that rate was 35%.
After 1996, U.S. corporations
could simply “check a box”,
allowing them to avoid paying this tax
as long as their money stayed overseas.
A year later, Ireland passed a similar law. Now,
companies only had to pay tax in the
country where their “key decisions”
were made. In practice, anywhere they
wanted. Or, even better, nowhere at all.
The trick was that no one was
enforcing consistency. In America,
Apple could argue its subsidiary was
genuinely Irish. Over in Ireland,
Apple could simultaneously argue it was
really based somewhere else, like Bermuda.
That was step one.
Apple had created a low-tax Irish
subsidiary. But it still needed to
move its international profit into that company.
When you walk into an Apple Store
in Munich and buy an iPhone,
that profit needs to somehow end up
in Apple Ireland, not Apple Germany.
The solution was intellectual property.
IP is the perfect vehicle for tax avoidance
because it’s (a) extremely valuable — who
could argue that the Apple logo
isn’t worth a fortune? and yet,
(b) extremely difficult to value — whose
to say it’s worth one trillion and not 1.2?
By moving around these priceless
though intangible patents, logos,
and other trademarks, Apple
could move its profit, too.
It simply gave the rights to use its IP outside
of the Americas to its Irish subsidiary. Then,
whenever it sold an iPhone
in Munich for, say, $100,
Apple Germany would have to pay Apple Ireland,
let’s say $98 for use of its trademark. Thus,
98% of the profit would be
attributed to low-tax Ireland.
But… there’s a wrinkle.
Officially, Ireland’s corporate tax rate is 12.5%.
Recall that to reduce this to less
than two percent, Apple declared its
Irish subsidiary a tax resident of somewhere
like Bermuda, where the rate was even lower.
Except… Ireland imposes a special 20% tax on
transfers to “known tax havens”… like Bermuda.
Apple, therefore, needed to transfer its money
through an intermediary — another company,
this time in the Netherlands, to which the
first Irish company would sub-license its IP.
Next, Apple created a second Irish company,
which sub-licensed the IP from the Dutch one.
Lastly, this second Irish company would license
its IP to Apple subsidiaries across the globe.
Now, all together:
You walk into a German Apple Store and buy an
iPhone. Apple Germany argues that most of the
value of that sale was derived from intellectual
property — property it doesn’t own. Therefore,
Apple Germany pays a “royalty”
to that second Irish company.
The second Irish company also doesn’t own
anything. It too pays a fee to the Dutch company.
The Dutch company does the same
— forwarding most of the money
it’s just received onto the first Irish company.
Finally, the first Irish company
claims its “key decisions” are
made in a small Caribbean country, where the
corporate tax rate is at or near 0%. Voila!
Apple pioneered this strategy — which
became known as the “Double Irish with a
Dutch Sandwich” — but it was by no means
the only corporation to take advantage.
Google, Microsoft, and Facebook all did
the same. During the 90s and early 2000s,
U.S. multinationals made an
increasing share of their
profits overseas — billions of dollars
of which made their way to Ireland.
And while most people assume
some level of tax shenanigans,
the astonishing scale of this effort
largely flew under the radar for years.
Much of what we know today is only
thanks to independent researchers
and academics like Emma Clancy,
Brian O’Boyle, and Kieran Allen.
Then, in 2013, as the public began taking notice,
the U.S. Senate held high-profile
hearings, attended by Tim Cook.
With the world’s attention focused on Ireland,
the country feigned innocence. Apple had
simply exploited a “loophole”. Never mind
that it had expressly written its
tax code to produce these results.
The Double Irish was no more, it
announced. Irish companies would
now be taxed in — if you can believe it… Ireland!
Apple’s first Irish subsidiary could no longer
claim to be a “tax resident” of, say, Bermuda.
But, not to worry! Generally speaking, tax
treaties supersede local laws. Companies,
therefore, could simply replace Bermuda with a
country that shared a tax treaty with Ireland.
For Apple, that ‘country’ was Jersey,
the British Crown Dependency with a
population of just over 100,000 people.
Problem solved.
Now, it should be clear by now that
Ireland is, in fact, a tax haven.
The question is: Is its economic success real?
Recall that Ireland is one of the
richest countries on the planet,
with a per-capita GDP of over $100,000, and
that its economy grew by 25% in 2015 alone.
Critics of its tax regime argue that this is
all just a statistical mirage — that the country
is little more than a Bermuda, Bahamas,
or British Virgin Islands with castles.
Consider, for example, what happened in
2015. Irish workers weren’t suddenly 25%
more productive. Nor did Irish
companies export 25% more goods.
No, what really happened is that
when Ireland closed the “Double
Irish” “loophole”, it opened
a new one. Starting in 2015,
companies could subtract from their tax
bill the full cost of any IP they purchased.
So, what did companies do? They “bought” a
whole lot of IP. (From themselves, of course)
Companies like Apple transferred an estimated
$270 billion worth of trademarks and
patents into their Irish subsidiaries.
And since on paper, trademarks are no
different from oil or refrigerators,
Ireland’s GDP grew by 25%.
This is what skeptics mean when
they say its economy isn’t “real”.
Even worse, while the benefits aren’t
real, they argue, there are real costs.
The dominance of foreign multinationals in tiny
Ireland has contributed to a housing crisis
that makes America’s look tame by comparison.
Between 1991 and 2007, Dublin home prices
increased by 429%, according to these researchers.
Secondly, the Irish economy
is incredibly dependent on
a very small number of American corporations.
Just ten are responsible for 60%
of the country’s corporate tax
receipts. The top three pay
about a third of the total.
From the recent boom to the busts of the
Great Recession and the DotCom bubble,
the Irish economy is fully
at the mercy of Washington.
In 2021, Ireland was pressured into signing an
OECD agreement that sets a 15% global minimum
corporate tax rate and re-allocates profits to
the country in which a sale physically occurred.
If the past is any indication, Ireland will
simply invent a new “loophole”. Still, the
risk remains that it will one day truly be forced
to change its ways and lose out on this revenue.
And not just revenue.
As proponents of Ireland’s tax
regime are quick to point out,
part of the implicit bargain struck
nearly 40 years ago between Apple and
Ireland was that the former provide
high-quality highly-paid employment.
The United States, along with much of the
world, experienced a baby boom following
the end of World War II. Twenty years
later, these millions of young adults
joined the workforce — producing this
steady, 40-year rise in employment.
Ireland’s baby boom, on the other hand, was about
30-years delayed and much more compressed. As
you can see, it suddenly had millions of
young, working-age people in the 1990s.
Apple and its peers put thousands
of these 20 and 30 years to work.
Today, as much as 10% of the Irish workforce is
employed by foreign companies — nearly
all American and nearly all in tech.
Apple’s 2020 press release about
its Irish “community” wasn’t a
total smokescreen — it truly does
employ more than just accountants.
Even if low taxes brought multinationals
in the first place, this argument goes,
they’ve stayed for its genuine
operational advantages.
Indeed, Ireland is now the only
English-speaking country in the
EU. It’s a mere six hours from New York
and its population is highly-educated.
Sure, Ireland is a tax haven, they might
admit, but its economic success is very real.
But what both those who argue Ireland’s
economy is ‘real’ and those who argue
it’s ‘fake’ misunderstand is that “real”
and “fake” aren’t contradictory. In fact,
these two sides of its economy are complementary.
Take, for instance, what happened in 2013.
Shortly after the explosive U.S. Senate hearings,
the European Union launched an
investigation into Apple’s tax practices.
And in 2016, it concluded that Ireland had
granted it special treatment. And while it is,
of course, entitled to set its own
tax laws, as a member of the EU,
it also agrees not to grant preferential
treatment to any one corporation.
The court — in a ruling that has since been
overturned and is now in the process of a
second appeal — ordered Apple to pay
Ireland $14 billion in unpaid taxes.
So, how did Ireland react to
this $14 billion windfall?
With outrage.
To the confusion of many Irish citizens,
their government launched an
immediate challenge to this ruling.
Now, you might be thinking “Of course
— better to turn down a small sum of
money today to preserve the larger flow tomorrow.”
But this was no “small” amount of money. Remember,
Ireland is a country of just 5 million
people. $14 Billion would’ve paid for the
country’s entire annual health budget
or seven years of transportation.
Let’s not forget that lower corporate tax
rates are merely an alternative
means of achieving the same goal.
The Irish government — like every other
government — is in the business of collecting
more taxes. So why turn down so much cash?
Especially since, in the eyes of Apple,
Ireland’s hands were clean — it didn’t
initiate the court case, the EU did.
Because… Ireland is not just a tax haven.
After all, there are safer, cheaper,
and more secretive places to stash
your profits. It isn’t even the lowest-tax
jurisdiction in Europe! Apple could surely
find a more “accommodating” government in a
smaller, less democratic Caribbean island.
What Ireland really sells — and what the Caribbean
can’t offer — is its untarnished reputation.
Yes, the ultra-low taxes
of the Cayman Islands. But
without the connotation of “the Cayman Islands”.
Here’s how it works:
First, Ireland’s real economy — the one in which
real people go to work every day and fix pipes,
connect servers, and sell computers
— creates the illusion of legitimacy.
Second, thanks to this illusion,
companies concerned about their image — like
Apple — choose Ireland as their tax shelter.
Third, in doing so, Apple inflates the country’s
economic health — creating the
appearance of unbelievable wealth.
Fourth and finally, this “economic miracle”
is seized upon by those with an agenda to
lower corporate tax rates, who argue “look what’s
possible when you’re just friendly to businesses”.
Without the “real”, in other words,
the “fake” wouldn’t exist. And without
the “fake”, neither would the “real”.
In that 2013 Senate hearing, Tim Cook proudly
proclaimed, quote, “Apple does not hold money
on a Caribbean Island,” and, quote, “does not
have a bank account in the Cayman Islands”.
That was true. And that’s
why Apple chooses Ireland.
The reason Ireland fought the
EU ruling was that something
more important than $14 billion was at stake.
Something extraordinarily valuable, yet
impossible to precisely value — much
like the intellectual property Apple moves
between its subsidiaries — its reputation.
In truth, many of the things we
value the most are also the most
difficult to measure — happiness,
love, creativity, and doing “good”.
We all want to do the most “good”.
But when we give, say, to a charity,
how do we ensure that we’re making
the most effective possible impact?
Well, in 2007, a few friends had
that same question and decided to
start GiveWell. They closely scrutinize
all the data we have on charities and
publish this information on the GiveWell website,
allowing you and I to compare the over 1.5 million
nonprofit organizations in the United States.
That way, when we go to donate, we know where
our money is going, what it’s doing, and who it’s
helping. These are non-partisan, cost-effective,
evidence-backed causes like preventing malaria,
solving vitamin deficiencies, and
incentivizing childhood vaccines.
We shouldn’t have to become experts on
charitable giving. When we shop for phones
or cars, we search for reviews. So why not
outsource that work to charity researchers?
What I like about GiveWell is that they don’t
take any fees. All of your money goes straight
to the charity of your choice. They’ve even
gone out of their way to advise me not to
disparage other charities, which to me is
a pretty clear indicator of their values.
Plus, right now, new donors can get
their entire donation matched — up to
$100 — before the end of the year, as long
as funds last. So hurry now while you still
can and go to Givewell.org or click the
link in the description or on screen now,
then choose “YouTube” and enter “PolyMatter”
at checkout to do twice as much good.